it looks like Scotland is going to have
another national vote to leave the
United Kingdom not even three years
after their last one if only we could
think of a reason Scotland wouldn't
remember something they just did I can't
think of anything the referendum is the
Scottish response to the UK's decision
to leave the European Union which is
surprising as the usual SCOTUS response
to anything is throwing fists and random
vowels at people congratulations on your
baby shower you get there get your baby
I know this does that's a basket of
potatoes but it looks like he's laying
eggs doesn't it like I said there's your
skin bill didn't I know just going to
piss him Yahtzee
of course Emeril was jumping on Twitter
to talk about the economic and political
ramifications of this decision 69 votes
in favour of Scottish independence nice
fortunately 69 isn't that popular in
Scotland cuz the only thing that blows
there is the food good night and back 5
cent bagpipes to backbite sure check out
this completely silver UK response this
Scottish independence referendum thing I
think the rest of the UK should get a
boat sing if we want them hashtag good
Colin Gotama
personally I'm very glad to see that the
Queen have gotten her Twitter account up
and running my name is what is something
the UK could offer Scotland to get them
to stay I've been so baby they could go
to stay if they like hold a big boom box
over their heads oh good idea what fine
Megan just a nice fresh sheep intestine
to gnaw on yeah yeah Jessi at the
Queen's funeral they get to throw the
first chair points very good